So this past Friday, just about every single
corporate media outlet uncritically repeated,
obviously false unemployment headlines, which
Donald Trump then used to claim everything's
going great in the economy, despite us still
being in the middle of the largest jobs downturn
in a very, very long time with historically
high unemployment rates.
Now, the crazy thing about this is I told
you guys this was going to happen just two
weeks ago.
If you listen to this podcast, if you watch
the YouTube clip.
I did a story called You're About to Get Slammed
with garbage math.
And in that story, I specifically said when
the economy starts to recover, you are going
to get hit with growth rates that will be
based on the absolute bottom of this disaster.
So I gave the example.
Air travel dropped 96 percent.
And then you saw a headline.
Air travel up one hundred and twenty percent.
Well, OK.
From the decreased by 96 percent.
No, it has doubled.
And I told you it would happen with GDP.
I told you it would happen with jobs numbers.
And it took only two weeks and we're now seeing
it.
But it's actually even worse because it's
based on admittedly incorrect numbers from
the Bureau of Labor Statistics.
Not only are they lying in exactly the way
that I predicted they would be lying.
They aren't even reporting what's actually
in the VLS jobs report.
And this is so important that everybody understand.
So all day Friday, Trump and corporate media
were reporting unemployment rate way down
to thirteen point three percent.
2.5 million jobs created.
The report says in it that because of what's
called the misclassification error, the unemployment
rate has been reported three months in a row
as being lower than it actually is and was.
This was reported by almost no corporate media.
And we're going to show you the actual numbers.
And one report from corporate media that actually
looked to get it right, but it was sort of
like swept under the rug.
So for context, remember, I want a recovery.
I want corona virus to end.
I want the economy to recover.
I never wanted anybody to die from corona
virus.
I don't want a crappy economy or death in
order to hurt Donald Trump and his reelection
chances.
That's an allegation that people like Donald
Trump Junior have made.
It's ridiculous.
OK.
But we have to tell the truth and the truth
is not being told.
So let's get right into the numbers.
Back in April.
The unemployment rate of fifteen percent was
reported fourteen point seven percent due
to what's called the classification error.
The real rate was 19 percent.
Now, for May, we just got the May numbers.
They are saying the unemployment rate is thirteen
point three percent, while the actual rate
is really sixteen point three percent.
Now, to be totally clear and honest, this
is still an improvement from April to May.
And this is still the worst unemployment we've
ever had.
Dating back to 1948 when the numbers started
being tracked the way that they are today.
So what the hell happened here?
What happened is that employees who should
be considered temporarily unemployed, which
does count towards the unemployment rate,
were instead classified as absent from work
for other reasons, temporarily unemployed
counts towards the unemployment rate that
we know as the U3.
That's the rate that we're talking about here.
If you're absent from work for other reasons,
it does not count towards the unemployment
rate.
Now, usually absent for other reasons would
be something like you're on a vacation or
you're on extended jury duty, you're taking
care of a child or relative.
That's very different than your business is
closed and you are unemployed, even if the
idea is you're going to go back to work when
that business reopens for some reason.
And we really don't know what.
I'm not implying that Trump tinkered with
the data.
There are very conspiratorial claims about
Trump force, the hand of the Bureau of Labor
Statistics.
It's a huge organization.
And absent evidence of that, I think it would
be irresponsible to suggest Trump demanded
fake numbers be published because they did
publish the real numbers.
They were just in a footnote.
For some reason, people who should have been
counted in the unemployment rate in April
and May were counted as this other category,
which artificially lowers the unemployment
rate.
The report says this happened due to corona
virus related business closures as unemployed
on temporary layoffs.
However, it is apparent that.
Not all such workers were so classified, they
claimed to be investigating why the Mishkat
classification error continues to occur.
So this has now happened three times.
In March, the real unemployment rate was five
point four.
They reported four point four in April.
The real unemployment rate was nineteen point
seven.
They reported fourteen point seven.
And in May, the new numbers, the real unemployment
rate is sixteen point three.
They reported thirteen point three.
So understand that from this same error, we
now have three months of headlines that are
wrong, almost exclusively reported in the
incorrect form by corporate media.
I found one instance of this being mentioned
on Friday.
Here's Steve Rattner on MSNBC who actually
said, hey, you know what?
There's different numbers there that are the
actual numbers.
Take a look through this.
I think for those of us who are into these
weeds are finding is there is a note in the
VLS report today that Asanov methodology specifically
relating to the koger problem and I won't
get into the weeds on that, but I feel like
there's noting that that issue has a three
percentage point impact on unemployment and
that and show that a number of economists
are thinking that the right number to be looking
at a small like 16 percent or sixteen point
three percent.
Now, again, understand, I am not blaming Trump.
It is true that a bunch of jobs were created
in May or at least rehabilitated jobs.
That's a good thing.
But the unemployment rate is still a record
high of more than sixteen point three percent.
The Trump administration has been going crazy
with the economists were wrong.
Well, unemployment was expected to hit 20
percent at its peak and it hit nineteen point
seven in April.
They just didn't report that number except
in a little footnote.
They reported it as fourteen point seven.
So the bragging about we know what's actually
going on.
The economists don't know.
They predicted 20.
They were way off.
It's all been been predicted accurately.
And I'm the first to tell you that economists
are notably bad at making economic predictions.
But none of this matters.
The Trump administration has not only been
touting these incorrect numbers for four days
now, they've already created campaign ads
around these incorrectly reported numbers.
The jobs report says unemployment is sixteen
point three percent.
We've never had anything this high short of
last month.
And they are claiming victory and saying let's
reelect Trump based on these record disaster
unemployment numbers.
They're living in a fantasy world.
And I fear that it is going to work.
And we're going to talk about this a little
more later on in the program